WE ARE A JUST ONE MEMBER SHORT
OF A QUORUM WE HAVE SIX.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HERE.
WE NOW HAVE SEVEN.
LUCKY LUCKY SEVEN MISTER
CALDERON.
THIS.
IS THE APRIL. EIGHTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
HEARING OF TE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
LET'S TAKE ROLE. PLEASE.
DALY
HERE.
MAY.
BIGELOW.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CHEN.
YOU.
COOLEY THEIR.
COOPER.
FRAZIER. PRESENT HIMSELF RIGHT
HERE.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A.
QUORUM LET'S A.
HANDLE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE ARE SIX.
SIX ITEMS
ANY QUESTIONS ON THOSE ITEMS.
IF NOT LET'S TO ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAY.
MAYES I BIGELOW.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON YOU ARE AYE CALDERON
AYE JENNIFER.
CAN I TO.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
FRAZIER. AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HARPER I.
EIGHT TWO ZERO.
EIGHT ZERO APPROVAL OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT TO
MISTER OBERNOLTE IS BILL.
AB TWENTY SIX ELEVEN HAS BEEN
PULLED.
FROM THE AGENDA BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
AND.
.
I SEE MS LOW MOAN IS HERE.
ONE WE TAKE FEES THEN IN.
YEAH IS ZERO.
THE M. MISLIM OWN IS NOT ONLY
NEXT UP WHICH IS ALSO FIRST ON
THE SIGN IN SHEET SO LET'S GO
AHEAD MISS LEMOND. WITH YOUR
BILL.
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY INSURANCE
REGARDING CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS
AND WILDFIRES.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AB NINETEEN TWENTY THREE COMES
AT A TIME WHEN MY DISTRICT
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES ARE STILL VERY MUCH
DEALING WITH OUR DISASTER
BETWEEN THE THOMAS FIRE AND
SUBSEQUENT MUDSLIDES. WE LOST
TWENTY TWO LIVES AND WELL OVER A
THOUSAND STRUCTURES INCLUDING
RESIDENCES AND BUSINESSES.
DEBRIS REMOVAL FOLLOWING A FIRE
IS ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL NOT ONLY
TO TRANSPORTATION TO GETTING
BACK TO NORMAL BUT ALSO FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THE DEBRIS IN ASH FROM
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL FIRES
CONTAINS HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
CREATED THROUGH THE BURNING OF
SYNTHETIC AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
WE HAVE FOUND FROM PAST FIRES
BUT IF CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS
REMOVAL HAPPENS AS OPPOSED TO
INDIVIDUALS PAIN PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS DEBRIS REMOVALS
HAPPENS FASTER AND AT A LOWER
COST OVERALL.
HOWEVER WE HAVE SEEN ISSUES IN
THE PAST WHERE INSURANCE
COMPANIES DID NOT END UP
COVERING DEBRIS REMOVAL OR
DISCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE
CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS REMOVAL
PROGRAM.
IN ORDER TO CLARIFY CONCERNS AND
STREAMLINE THE RECOVERY PROCESS.
THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT IF
PRESIDENTIAL PROPERTY OWNER HAS
AT INSURANCE OF VIOLENT IF THEY
CAN VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATE.
IN A CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS REMOVAL
PROGRAM IN EFFECT AT THE TIME OF
THE WILDFIRE THAT INSURANCE WILL
COVER COSTS FROM THE
CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS REMOVAL.
FOLLOWING A DISASTER AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING ALL
THAT WE CAN TO HELP RETURN TO A
SENSE OF NORMALCY TO THE LIVES
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND REMOVE.
ROADBLOCKS TO REBUILDING.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ROBERT
HERSELF FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AS WELL AS AYE TONY'S
SIGNAL.
SINGER ALI.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
LA.
.
BEFORE WE FOR WE HEAR FROM MR
HER WELL.
I WANT TO REFER.
TO PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS.
MISLIM MONA.
WE HAVE DISCUSSED.
THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL YOUR BILL IS A VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT THE BILL HAS
REAL VALUE.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IT FAIL
TODAY.
SO I'D LIKE TO WERE SUGGEST TO
OUR COMMITTEE THAT.
WE INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY OUR. OR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
.
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED.
SO JUST TO.
THINGS MOVING I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND.
.
MOVE.
TO.
INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS.
LISTED ON PAGE THREE.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND SO
WILL.
WELL HOLD THAT THAT MOTION AND
THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND HEAR
FROM THE.
.
FROM YOUR WITNESSES GO AHEAD MR
AROUND A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROBERT
WORLD THAT THE COMMISSIONER FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
MENTIONED.
WE'VE GOT A UPWARDS OF A DECADE
OF EXPERIENCE NOW WITH THESE
CONSOLIDATED.
DEBRIS REMOVAL PROGRAMS AFTER
DISASTERS WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND OTHER RELEVANT
ENTITIES.
OUR THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE
HAS COME A LONG WAY IN THE PAST
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS ABOUT. A FOR
EXAMPLE AFTER THE DEVASTATING
FIRES LAST YEAR THE TOXICITY OF
SOME OF WHAT HAS BURNED UP A AND
A TORN ASUNDER THESE COMMUNITIES
LIKE THAT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
THE MOUNT.
AND SO A WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
OF THIS MEASURE IT'S INTENDED TO
REALLY CODIFY WHAT HAS BEEN FOR
THE PAST ALMOST DECADE THE
CURRENT PRACTICE WE SHOULD NOTE
THAT THE CURRENT PRACTICE AND
THIS BILL. IT'S VOLUNTARY ON THE
HOMEOWNER NO HOMEOWNER IS BEING
COMPELLED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS REMOVAL
PROCESS IF THEY DON'T WANT TO WE
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THIS IS
BEEN. HISTORICALLY A WIN WIN
WIN.
IT'S BETTER FOR THE HOMEOWNER.
OUR BECAUSE THINGS GET DONE
FASTER AND IN MANY CASES AT
SCALE ALSO OF THE DEBRIS IS
REMOVED UP OF MORE MORE CHEAPLY
GENERALLY SPEAKING. IT'S BETTER
FOR THE INSURER.
BOTH TIME FRAMES AND
ECONOMICALLY AND IT'S BETTER FOR
THE LOCAL ENTITY OR OTHER STATE
OR FEDERAL ENTITY THAT'S
OVERSEEN THE DEBRIS REMOVAL THAT
COULD BE IN MANY CASES IT'S THE
LOCAL COUNTY. OR COUNTIES
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
DISASTER OR OTHERS I WOULD JUST
NOTE.
THROUGH A THROUGH THE CHAIR ON
THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE THERE'S A A HANDFUL OF
THINGS THAT TO CONCERN US THAT
WE SHOULD JUST WANTED TO MENTION
FOR THE RECORD. UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
THE REGULATION TO SIX NINE FIVE
POINT ONE EIGHT THREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURTREGULATION
DEBRIS REMOVAL IS CONSIDERED A
PART OF REPLACEMENT BECAUSE.
AND WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
CURRENT LAW.
TO A FIVE ONE POINT FIVE AT THE
INSURANCE CODE FOLLOWING THE
DECLARED DISASTER.
COUNTY OR WHATEVER THE IN AGENCY
IS THAT IT'S PICKING CONTROL
DEBRIS REMOVAL HAS TWO YEARS.
TO LET THE INSURER KNOW WHAT THE
COSTS ARE.
IT'S ONE YEAR IF IT'S NOT A
DECLARED DISASTER
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD TAKE
THAT.
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS IN A DECLARED
DISASTER AND CUT IT DOWN TO SIX
WE FEAR THAT WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THAT WILL BE TO SHIFT WHAT
SHOULD BE PRIVATE INSURER COSTS.
OVER ONTO PUBLIC ENTITIES SUCH
AS COUNTIES WHICH WILL ALREADY
BE STRAPPED FOR RESOURCES IN
DEALING WITH.
THE DISASTER THAT JUST OCCURRED
OR THE RELEVANT STATE OR FEDERAL
AGENCY THAT MAY COULD BE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS OR WHOEVER
THAT MAY BE OVERSEEING THAT. WE
WILL ALSO JUST POINT OUT THAT WE
FEEL LIKE THE IMMUNITY LANGUAGE.
WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
NOTION THAT INSURERS ARE TO BE
IMMUNE FOR ACTING IN GOOD FAITH
IN THIS AREA FAR FROM IT. BUT WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THE IMMUNITY
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I SAW LATE LAST
NIGHT. IS OVERLY BROAD AND COULD
THEORETICALLY PROVIDE IMMUNITY
TO ENSURE OR JUST FOR THE
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO.
A COMPLY AS OPPOSED TO ACTUALLY
COMPLYING.
SO WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE AMENDMENTS HOPEFULLY
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT COULD BE.
I DEALT WITH OVER TIME.
BECAUSE WHICH IS THAT THE
MEMBER SHOULD KNOW ABOUT
SHIFTING THESE COSTS ON TO
LOCALS IS PROBABLY OF CONCERN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
BURRELL.
AND NOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
MUSLIM.
GO AHEAD SIR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TONI
CINDERELLA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE OP I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING MORE TO ADD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OTHER THAN TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
.
DE MISLIM OWN I DIDN'T GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO COMMENT ON THE
AMENDMENTS BUTTA I'M I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE OKAY
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS SO
I THINK THAT WE SHARE THE SAME
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AND.
AND TO MOVE IT FORWARD AYE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE WHAT THEY ARE A
HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SOME OF THE
DETAILS AND THE AMENDMENTS I'M
AT THAT I THINK. ARE IMPORTANT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MATTER TO
YOU AND TO THE DISTRICT YOU
REPRESENT AND. AND CERTAINLY
WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS SO.
.
ANY ASPECT THAT YOU LIKE TO
DISCUSS.
WERE OPEN TO DISCUSSION THINK
IF I THINK TO HAVE NOTHING TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A. IN AN
EXPEDITIOUS WAY THIS IS
IS THE MASTER.
FOR THE TIME BEING.
THANK YOU MISS LAMONT FARTHER
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON. ON
THE MOTION.
MISTER GRAYSON.
THAT THANK YOU CHAIR OF GOING
BACK TO OF THE SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE THAT CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
IT'S CURRENTLY TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS IT'S TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THAT.
UNDER DECLARE DISASTER A
GUBERNATORIAL HE DECLARED
DISASTER IN A NORMAL NON
DISASTER SITUATION WHERE THERE'S
TO REMOVE NECESSARY IT'S TWELVE
MONTHS
SO IN EITHER CASE YOU EITHER
CUTTING IT FROM TWENTY FOUR TO
SIX.
IN A DISASTER OR TWELVE TO SIX
AND A NON DISASTER BUT WERE
OBVIOUSLY FOCUSING ON THE
DISASTER. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THESE CONSOLIDATED DEBRIS
REMOVAL PROGRAMS TEND TO OCCUR
GOT IT SO.
EVEN ONLY IN IN MY MIND I'M
THINKING WHAT WHILE SIX MONTHS
FROM THE TIME OF OF REMOVAL FROM
THE TIME OF COMPLETION SEEMS
LIKE. THAT'S PRETTY ADEQUATE
TIME BUT WHY IS IT THAT YOU
WOULD YOU WOULD SAY SIX MONTHS
IS TOO SHORT OF A TIME IS IT.
BUT I MEAN IF I'M CLEANING OFF A
PIECE OF PROPERTY.
BUT. IF I UNDERSTAND RIGHT WE'RE
NOT TALKING THAT JUST A SINGLE
PIECE OF PROPERTY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
SOME CASES MULTIPLE CONTRACTORS
OR GROUPS THAT ARE HANDLING THE
DEBRIS REMOVAL. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT'S LESS THAN
CRYSTAL CLEAR IN THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S GOING INTO THE BILL.
WHAT?
REMOVED ON YOUR PROPERTY REMOVED
THE WHOLE THE WHOLE SWATH OF THE
DISASTER AREA AT MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER CIGNA RALLY CAN MAYBE
TALK ABOUT THIS EVEN A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
YES ON ESSENTIALLY THE DEBRIS
GETS REMOVED THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD AFTER THE
DISASTER RIGHT AND SO IT WOULD
BE THREE TO FOUR MONTHS. PLUS
THE SIX MONTHS SO LET'S SAY IT'S
FOR EVEN FIVE MONTHS DOWN THE
ROAD PLUS THE SIX MONTH THAT'S
ELEVEN MONTHS.
.
SO AT A MINIMUM IT'S REDUCE THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE TIME FRAME
FROM THE CURRENT TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS.
TO TWELFTH TWO ELEVEN TWELVE
AND IN ADDITION THAT TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS IS.
AFTER THE FIRST ACTUAL CASH
VALUE PAYMENT IS MADE WHICH IS
USUALLY SIXTY DAYS DOWN THE ROAD
FROM THE DISASTER SO TECHNICALLY
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE'S ABOUT
A TWENTY SIX MONTH PERIOD OF
TIME. FOR THE INSURER TO SUBMIT
THE CLAIM TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND STILL RECEIVE THE
FULL BENEFIT OF THE INSURANCE
POLICY
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMONA IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THERE. THERE'S
DEFINITE SOME ROOM THAT YOU
COULD.
THAT YOU NEED DON'T WORK ON HERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT OTHERS
ADEQUATE TIME. RIGHT AND THAT'S
OUR HOPE AND JUST TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE IN LAKE COUNTY FOR THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FIRES IT
TOOK THEM ENTIRE TWO YEARS EVERY
COUNTIES IN A DIFFERENT SPACE.
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
AND THE DEBRIS I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW I HAD A A COLLEAGUE TO COME
TO MY DISTRICT IN JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF DEBRIS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GOLDEN GATE YELL
SIZE FULL OF DEBRIS SO IT'S IT'S
A MUCH MORE COMPLICATED PROCESS
AND I THINK HAVING HAD A COUNTY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND THAT TOOK
THE ENTIRE TWO YEARS I'D TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT I THINK EIGHT AT
IT LENDS A CASE FOR REALLY
REEXAMINING THE SIX MONTH IS THE
RIGHT. AMOUNT OF TIME I MEAN
THIS IS ONE OF MULTIPLE ISSUES
THAT HAPPENED SO. OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE DONE I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
IS JUST ALVY WATCHING IT AS
THAT.
GOES THROUGH.
AND.
THEY HAVE A DEPOSITION LATER.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON I'D
LIKE TO GIVE UP OR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND.
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON YOUR
QUESTION AND.
.
AND SOME OF THE DETAILS I THINK
IT JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
CLARIFICATION SO THAT THE IN YOU
DID KNOW CORRECTLY.
THE SIX MONTH PERIOD ISN'T.
A TIME FRAME IN WHICH DEBRIS
NEEDS TO BE REMOVED AND ITS NOT
A SIX MONTHS PERIOD THAT
BURDENS.
THE POLICYHOLDER.
SIX MONTHS PERIOD FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AFTER IT'S COMPLETED
ITS WORK
SEND A BILL TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY.
BEFORE WE EVEN ENDED THIS
A POLICY HOLDER HAS ALREADY.
AGREED TO THE PROCESS AND
ASSIGNED THE RIGHTS TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF THE BURDEN ON THE
POLICY HOLDER COMMENT FRANKLY IS
NOT WELL TAKEN.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND TO.
.
YES.
MISTER COOLEY.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK.
LOOKING BACK AT THIS OF COURSE
TO
THE REMOVAL ON A LARGE SCALE WAS
FIRST DONE HALF THE OAKLAND
HILLS FIRE.
TO.
CORD AND PROGRAM ELIHU HARRIS
FORMER SENATOR FORMER MEMBER
THIS BODY. WAS THEN MAYOR
WORKING ON THAT.
.
AND THIS SORT OF SCALE I MEAN
THE WAY THESE PROGRAMS WORK
ACTUALLY.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE AT TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO PUT THE DEBRIS.
SIMPLY IDENTIFIED WHAT IS THE
PLACE OF DEBRIS WILL BE REMOVED
TO THAT THAT ITSELF IS A PART A
PLAN. THAT ADDS TO THE LEAD
TIME.
THERE HAS TO BE YOU HAVE TO KIND
OF PAVED THE WAY. FOR THE
REMOVAL TO START TO HAPPEN.
SENATORS A LOT OF WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A DISASTER THERE IS
A LOT OF SCALE INVOLVED AND
THERE IS A LOT OF. GET
EVERYTHING LINED UP.
BEFORE DEBRIS REMOVAL HAPPEN.
SO I DO THINK THIS IDEA THAT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A PROCESS OF
IN SHE LOTS WILL BE CLEARED. AND
OUR NEEDS TO BE SOME INFORMING
IN A TIMELY WAY BUT EVEN SIX
MONTHS.
EVERYONE A PROTEST IT'S GOING TO
HAVE A CHANCE GET THEIR SYSTEMS
IN ORDER.
THE COUNTIES A COURSE ADMINISTER
THEIR PROPERTY TAX RULES SAY NO
THE.
.
AP ENDS FOR THE PROPERTIES
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT'LL.
KIND OF.
EASE THE WAY FOR THIS.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT THE
AMENDMENTS I JUST WANNA KNOW
THAT.
.
ONE THING'S A CAUGHT MY EYE UPON
READING THE BILL'S I JUST KIND
OF WENT THROUGH IS THAT OPT IN
PROVISION.
AND OPTIM PROVISIONS ARE
ACTUALLY NOT THE SIMPLEST THING
TO OPERATE.
A HEARING CALIFORNIA AFTER THE
LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE THEY
PASSED THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTIAL EARTHQUAKE RECOVERY
FUND WHICH HAD AN OPT IN PROGRAM
PARTICIPATE.
AND WITHIN TWO YEARS.
BECAUSE THE OPT IN MECHANICS
HAVE NOT BEEN WORKED OUT.
THAT WAS REPEALED AND OF REPEAL
OF LED BY AN INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
JOHN GARAMENDI.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OFFERED.
BREAKING IT DOWN TO.
MORE SPECIFIC MECHANICS OF.
IF SOMEONE WANTS TO OPT IN THE
MEMORIALIZED BY PROVIDED FOR THE
TO COUNTY WHICH INCLUDE SHARED
WITH THE.
INSURERS OF THE SERVICE HOWEVER
KNOWS WHAT THE RULES ARE. IS
ACTUALLY SORT OF SWEATING THE
DETAILS.
THAT IS VERY APPROPRIATE FOR
POST DISASTER ENVIRONMENT.
TO EXPLAIN HOW THE MECHANICS OF
OP THAT ACTUALLY WORK AND WHO'S
IN WHO'S DOT HOUSE MEMORIALIZED
AND SET UP A WORKABLE PROCESS.
SO I'VE TO.
PRE SHOULD READ THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK THE.
THEY ARE RESPONSIVE NOT JUST TO
THE ISSUE BUT.
OUR HISTORY ARE THE STATUTES.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
COOLEY FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
MEMBERS WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. AND THEN
WE'LL DO A VOTE ON THE.
ON ON THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ASSUMING THE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCLUDED SO ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAY.
MAYES I BIGELOW.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
DO I COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER BUT COOPER AYE FRAZIER
PLAY FRAZIER AYE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON.
I THINK I HARPER ON.
HARPER I.
TWELVE TO ZERO EVEN.
THANK YOU.
.
THE EL ARE THERE PERSONS HERE
WILL IT WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ANY.
PORT POSITIONS
COMES A COUPLE.
MARK TECHNO WITH PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS ASSOCIATION
AMERICA WITH IM MEMBERS WE
REMOVE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
CATHERINE PUT ABOUT AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE ROOM REMOVE
OPPOSITION APPRECIATE THE WORK
ON THIS.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS GOOD
MORNING SURE MICKEY REPRESENTING
THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES THANK YOU
FOR. THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
REMOVE OPPOSITION.
MORNING CARA CROSS TO THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WITH AMENDMENTS WE
ALSO REMOVE PARA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. OTHER
ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL.
THE OTHER NO PERSONS OPPOSING OF
MISLIM OWN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO CLOSE IN.
I RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
THEN WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE
WEBSITE.
BUT WE NEED A MOTION ON THE BILL
WHICH WOULD WHICH INCLUDES THE
AMENDMENTS.
MOTION AND SECOND THANK YOU
MARK.
NOW WILL BE VOTING ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I THINK THE LOW.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON.
GEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER. COOPER FRAZIER A FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE.
SO TENTH ZERO UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN SO
THE OTHER MEMBERS CANNELLA.
THANK YOU MISS FORMA.
WHO'S NEXT IN SIGN IN ORDER.
SIR.
MS BROOKS ON AWAY.
CALDERON HAD TO STEP OUT.
MISTER NAZARIAN I THOUGHT I SAW
MISTER NAZARIAN.
I'M.
AND MR FELIZ MISTER FLORA HERE.
YOU'RE PRESENTING.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT THE HAIRCUT
TO.
FOR.
IN ITS IN ITS IN ITS A GOOD
HAIRCUT I'M I DON'T MEAN TO CAST
ANY ASPERSIONS AT ALL.
NO NONE TAKEN CARE.
WELL JUST MISTER FLOOR YOU.
THE HALF.
BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
REPRESENTING.
AB THIRTY ONE HUNDRED ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMAN FLORA.
AB THIRTY ONE HUNDRED TO EXPAND
EXISTING MENINGITIS RECEPTION.
THE MEMBERS OF CAL FIRE AS YOU
KNOW EXISTING LAWS DEVILISH IS A
MINUTE DOT IS PRESUMPTION FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
PROBATION OFFICERS AND CITY AND
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS.
HOWEVER CAL FIREFIGHTER MEMBERS
AND NOT BEEN INCLUDED IN THIS
PRESUMPTION EVEN THOUGH MORE
THAN EIGHTY PERCENT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO. INVOLVE
RESPOND LOCAL BRINGS THESE JUST
LIKE OTHER THEIR COUNTERPARTS.
AB THIRTY ONE HUNDRED ONE SURE
THAT ALL PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS OR FOR THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. HERE TESTIFIED
SUPPORTERS THERE AND READ REPS
THINK CAL FIRE LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE.
NO MISTER COOPER YOU'VE CONFUSED
EVERYONE BECAUSE THERE'S TO
MOTIONS BUT NO SECONDS
SO WERE. WE NEED TO CONVERT ONE
OF THOSE TO A SECOND.
YEAH YEAH YOU GOT OKAY OKAY I'M
CONFUSED TOO YEAH.
BUT WE HAVE THEM SO DO WE HAVE
CLEARLY OF A SECOND.
AS MOTION AND SECOND OF PLEASE
GO AHEAD MISTER REED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND READ REVIEWS AND CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS.
THIS JUST SIMPLY GIVES HIM A
BENEFITTED EVERY SINGLE LOCAL
FIREFIGHTER HAS.
AND THAT THAT'S IT PEN WEEK I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO.
BEAUTIFUL THANK MISTER REED.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST IT.
OR NO PERSONS SIR.
SEARCH ANY COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF NOT THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING
ELSE MISTER HOOPER AVE HALF A
MISTER FLOOR RESPECT THE FBI
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU ROLL
CALL VOTE. DALY AYE DALY AYE ME.
MAYES I BIGELOW.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON.
GEN NOT CHEN AYE CHIU. CHU AYE
COOLEY.
COOPER BY COOPER AYE FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER NINE HARPER
AYE.
NINE THIS ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY WELL DONE MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU.
STILL WAITING ON MS BIRTH.
MISTER OTHER YOU ARE OKAY.
YEAH.
COOPER BLOCKED MY VIEW.
YOU KNOW IT WAS THE GLARE AT.
HE'S GONE SO HE COULD SEE IF IT.
WELCOME. WHERE IT IS HERE? YES
ON THE INTERNET.
WELCOME IS BURKE.
BIGELOW CHAIR.
DALY.
AND MEANS FOR ALL TIME.
THIS IS A SIMILAR ISSUE THAT WE
LOOK AT LAST YEAR.
BEFORE YOU IT'S A RESULT OF
COUNTLESS HOURS OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW DRIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOW MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN EVER WE MANDATE INSURANCE
WE HAVE HIGHER GAS PRICES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND DRIVERS ARE
SPENDING MORE TIME ON THE ROAD
DUE TO LONG COMMUTES TO WORK.
THE RISING COSTS OF CAR REPAIRS
ISRAEL AND COULD ULTIMATELY LEAD
TO HIGHER INTEREST ASSURANCE
PRICES FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IT DOES NOT
UNDUE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE REGULATIONS ON LABOR
RATE SURVEYS BUT RATHER PROVIDES
A STATUTORY METHOD. THAT
COMPLEMENTS THE EXISTING
DEPARTMENT REGULATIONS FOR
INSURERS TO USE IN THE SURVEYING
AUTO BODY REPAIR SHOPS TO
DETERMINE THE PREVAILING. THE
PREVAILING AUTO BODY RATE LABOR
RATE IN PARTICULAR IN GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS INSURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
BY LAW TO CONDUCT A LABOR EIGHT
SURVEY AND MANY INSURERS DO NOT
CONDUCT ELABORATE SORRY. AND MY
BILL ACKNOWLEDGES THAT.
BUT ENSURE THAT DO CONDUCT A
VOLUNTARY LABOR RATE SURVEY USE
IT AS A TOOL FOR TWO MAIN
REASONS. THE FIRST IS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT A FAIR PRICE TO PAY IN
A LOCATION FOR A STANDARD REPAIR
JOB AND THE SECOND IS TO PRINT
PROVED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. THAT THEY'VE ACTED
FAIRLY IN THE EVENT OF PAYING
AUTO BODY REPAIR SHOPS COME.
WITH THEIR COMPLAINTS TO THE
OTHER FROM THE AUTO BODY REPAIR
SHOPS.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE A BALANCED APPROACH AND
IS ANOTHER METHODOLOGY TO
CONDUCT A VOLUNTARY LABOR RATE
SURVEY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
A SURVEY AT TO HAVE A RANDOM
MINIMUM A THIRTY QUALIFIED SHOPS
OR THIRTY PERCENT OF GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATIONS WHICH OF ITS GREATER.
THE SURVEY RESULTS MUST BE FILED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT EVERY TWELVE
MONTHS.
AUTO BODY REPAIR SHOPS INCLUDED
A SURVEY MUST MEETS BUT
SPECIFIED EQUIPMENT INSURANCE
AND LICENSING REQUIREMENTS TO
AVOID INCLUDING THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL SPECIFIES
DETAILED QUESTIONS THAT MUST BE
ASKED ON THE SURVEY THEY ARE IN
STATUTE IN THIS BILL. WITH
REGARDS TO GREG GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
THAT MAY BE SURVEYED I PROPOSE
THREE DIFFERENT OPTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BOUNDARIES AT
THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS AS DEFINED
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
REGULATIONS.
CONTINUES ZIP CODES WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AREAS AS ESTABLISHED
BY THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ARE THE THREE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. THESE
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED EXTENSIVELY IN OUR
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT POINT OUT THAT.
AS WE CONTINUE TO FINE TUNE THIS
BILL CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT
HAS SIXTEEN LABOR EIGHT SURVEYS
ON FILE.
AND THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS USED
RANGE FROM TWENTY ONE TO THIRTY
NINE AREA STATEWIDE. AND MOST OF
THEM BREAK UP LA INTO SMALLER
AREAS RANGING FROM ABOUT ONE TO
TWELVE AREAS. AYE THAT'S
SERGEANTS TO PASS THAT
INFORMATION OUT TO YOU SO THAT
YOU HAVE A RECORD OF THAT.
I'VE YOU'RE PREVAILING LABOR IT
SURVEYED DETERMINED BY ITS
SURVEY TO BE THE STARTING POINT
OF A NEGOTIATION BETWEEN AN AUTO
BODY SHOP ANY INSURER.
I HAVE EVEN INCLUDED LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT ALLOWS BOTH
PARTIES TO NEGOTIATE A HIGHER OR
LOWER RATES.
THE BILL ALSO STATES THAT THE
SURVEY PREVAILING RATE SHALL NOT
BE THE MINIMUM NOR THE MAXIMUM
RATE FOR ANY SPECS SPECIFIC
CLAIM IT'S SIMPLY A STARTING
POINT TO BEGIN NEGOTIATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR AYE. FOR ALLOWING
ME THE TIME TODAY TO REALLY GO
THROUGH THIS BILL IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND WE SPENT
LIKE I SAID A LOT OF HOURS ON
IT.
WITH ME TODAY I'M I HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND TO
END THOUGH NOW WILL GO TO YOUR
WITNESSES SAY MISTER GUNNING
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MICHAEL GUNNING
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION.
OF FIRST OFF I JUST HAVE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
HER PERSEVERANCE AND
PERSISTENCY IN THIS PROCESS.
THERE IS A LEVEL INVOLVEMENT
THAT WE RARELY SEE HERE AND WANT
TO THANK YOU PALM SHE SHE WAS AT
ALL THE MEETINGS CRACK OF THE
WHIP MAKING SURE WE MOVE
FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OTHER MEMBERS
THANK YOU OF COURSE FOR JOINING
ON IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OF
THIS IS CLEARLY A SLIMMED DOWN
VERSION OF.
I AB SIXTEEN SEVEN ON WHICH
PASSED LAST YEAR. YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR SOME OPPONENTS COME UP HERE
AND I THINK SOME MEMBER BURKE IS
ALREADY OUTLINED THE CHANGES
WE'VE MADE BUT THIS DOES NOT
REPLACE THE DEPARTMENTS
REGULATIONS THE DEPARTMENT STILL
HAS THEIR REGULATIONS. THIS
COMPLIMENTS THOSE REGULATIONS IN
ALLOWS INSURERS TO PERFORM A
SURVEY IN A DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGY AND AS YOU HEARD
SURVEYS ARE VOLUNTARY AND
MAJORITY OF INSURERS DON'T TO
HIM.
WE'VE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL SO AND
MY FRIEND JACK MADONNA GETS
APPEARANCE SAYS NO. HE'S GOTTEN
EVERYTHING ARE BILLS NOT WHAT WE
SAW LAST YEAR.
AND OF COURSE THE OTHER THING
IS STATED IN THE ANALYSIS
STEERING HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
HERE AND SO IT'S STILL THE LAW
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE TO BE TOLD
WHERE WOULD THAT THEY CAN GET
THEIR CAR REPAIRED AT ANY SHOP
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO DICTATE.
WHERE IT IS SO THIS IS A MODEST
PROPOSAL THAT WE THINK WILL HELP
KEEP CONSUMER PREMIUMS LOW AND
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAIR OF THE MORNING OUR MONTHLY
SHOT ON BEHALF OF.
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS I
TOO WOULD LIKE THINGS AND THE
MOVE BURKE.
FOR ADDRESSING MANY ISSUES
RAISED BUT AUTO DEALERS HOW CAR
MANUFACTURERS AND THE BODY
SHOP'S.
THE BILL IS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THE RISING COST OF CAR REPAIRS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT DOES
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES FOR
INSURERS TO CONDUCT FAVORITE
SURVEY OTHER THAN WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT ADOPTED.
IT IS A PRODUCT OF A.
.
LONG MANY HOURS IN THE GOSHI
ASIANS AND COMPROMISES SO WITH
THAT RESPECT WE I WOULD LIKE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR FELICIANO OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
CATHERINE PAPER AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION AND THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
SHERRI MCKEE REPRESENT THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND SUPPORT
ABOUT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS OR BROKERS WERE
SUPPORT THE BILL GIVEN.
EDWIN LOMBARD REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BLACK BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION BAY PACK IN THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK PASTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
TERRELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROB
HER OUT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WE. AS OF THIS MOMENT
DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL. WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT I HOPE THE AUTHOR AND
OTHERS APPRECIATE. THE MAGNITUDE
OF THAT ARM I WHICH IS NOW IN
THE ANALYSIS COMMON NUMBER TWO
TALKS ABOUT AND THE AUTHOR
TALKED ABOUT THIS LENGTHY
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS FOR THE
RECORD IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE WAS
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED FROM THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS UP UNTIL TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN WE ATTENDED OUR
FIRST MEETING OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND SO I THINK THE MEMBERSHIP
JUST BE AWARE OF THAT.
AND THE MEETING THAT WE DID
ATTEND I THOUGHT WAS A
PRODUCTIVE ONE AND WHILE WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS ON ISSUES THAT WERE TO
LET THE PROCESS PLAY OUT. AND
SEE HOW THOSE GET HANDLED.
IF PEOPLE WANT IT I HEAR MORE
ABOUT SOME OF THE DETAILS OF
THOSE CONCERNS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER CIGARETTE ONLY. WHO HAS
SPENT HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
HOURS ON THIS ISSUE WAS MORE
THAN HAPPY TO DETAIL THAT BUT IN
THE SAKE OF TIME FOR NOW UNLESS
NECESSARY? I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER HER RAIL.
STILL ADD UP BUT NOT ON
SUPPORTERS ANYMORE SUPPORTERS.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THE.
I'M I'M A TWEENER SAYS NOW THE
RAIN I'M OKAY WERE ON TWEENER
TIME RIGHT NOW THANK YOU GO
AHEAD SIR AYCLIFFE COSTS AND WE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
THE NEW CAR DEALERS REALLY
APPRECIATE
SPONSOR THE AUTHOR THE STAFF
YOUR STAFF SENATE STAFF.
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS STAFF
WE'VE HAD AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD A VERY LONG PROCESS.
THROUGH THAT PROCESS NEW CAR
DEALERS WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
AGREEMENTS ON A NUMBER OF POINTS
I.
WILL SAY TO YOU IT'S CLOSE TO
SEVENTEEN.
AND SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS AND THE
COMMITTEES ARE TO CONTINUE TO
FINE TUNE SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE
BUT WITH THAT WE ARE VERY HAPPY
TO BE.
ALRIGHT.
AND NOW A IF THERE ARE NO MORE
TWEETERS WILL GO TO THE
OPPONENTS
S. IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
TO.
CA.
IN A FOCUSED.
FAIRLY BRIEF WAY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
JACK MADONNA FROM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTO BODY ASSOCIATION
AND I WANT TO START OUT FIRST BY
THANKING ASSEMBLY. LOVE MEMBER
BURKE FOR HUH HER EFFORTS AND
OUR STAFF TO THEY HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT IN TRYING
TO ADDRESS ALL OUR CONCERNS.
AND YOU HAVE ADDRESSED MANY OF
THE CONCERNS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THEY'RE STILL.
SOME OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
AND WE'VE OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER BUT.
SO WITH THAT BUT I WANT TO SAY
THAT THE AUTO BODY ASSOCIATION
AND THE MEMBERS.
HAVE ALWAYS SAID THE POSITIONS
ALWAYS BEEN IF AN INSURANCE
COMPANY WANTS TO DO A SURVEY. AS
LONG AS IT'S FAIR AND REASONABLE
THERE OKAY WITH IT THAT'S REALLY
THEIR POSITION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
FAIR AND REASONABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE BILL STILL DOES NOT QUITE.
ADDRESSED THOSE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT NOW ARE
JUST FOCUS ON ONE ISSUE I KNOW A
YOU MENTIONED THE OF THE TIME
FRAME BUT I'M GONNA FOCUS ON THE
GEOGRAPHICAL ISSUE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL IN THE MAJOR ISSUE
HERE. AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN
OUTLINED IN THE.
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SO THE GEOGRAPHICAL ISSUE.
DE AND I KNOW THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IS TAKEN SOME AMENDMENTS
TO INCLUDE.
THAT THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BE
IN THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THAT.
FIRST OF ALL.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH.
THAT THE BODY SHOP'S OF MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT IS VERY LARGE
IT INCLUDES A DIFFERENT CITIES
AND DIFFERENT LOCAL MARKETS AND
COUNTIES.
AND SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT'S
IT'S UNFAIR FOR CERTAIN SHOPS
BODY SHOPS THAT ARE IN HIGH RENT
DISTRICT.
OF OR MAYBE IN AN AREA IN THIS
PARTICULAR CITY THAT THEY HAVE
TO PAY HIGHER MINIMUM WAGE TO BE
COMPARED WITH OTHER SHOPS IN A
LARGER AREA MAYBE THE COUNTY.
WHERE THE LOWER THE RATES ARE
CLEAR THE RENTS ARE LOWER SO
WHEN YOU DO AN AVERAGE?
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE SHOPS THAT?
ARE IN THE LOW RENT DISTRICT
ARE CHARGING LESS BUT IF YOU DO
AN AVID THEY END UP GETTING A
WINDFALL IN THE SHOPS THAT
CHARGE MORE. END UP GETTING PAID
LESS AND SO THAT IS THE DILEMMA
THAT'S WHAT WE. THAT'S REALLY
THE ISSUE WERE STRUGGLING WITH
WE'VE ASKED FOR SOME SORT OF.
PROCESS TO AT LEAST COMPENSATE
THE SHOP TO HAVE TO PAY MORE.
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC REASONS FOR
HIGHER RENT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE SORT OF WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH WE BASS WERE
PARTICULAR RANGE OF RATES MAYBE.
OF THAT ARE REASONABLE.
BUT THIS IS THE STRUGGLE AND
THIS IS THE REASON WHY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL SO. WITH THAT SAID.
AGAIN WE WE WANT TO THANK THE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ALL OUR
EFFORTS BUT WE CONTINUE TO
REMAIN A REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR.
OTHER OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
MATT BROUGHT WITH PRODDING GAS
MANY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE MACHINISTS
WERE OPPOSED TO THE DEL
RESPECTFULLY. I'M WE THINK THAT
EXISTING SEE I REGULATION IS
STRONG IT KEEPS LABOR RATE WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. ARM SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE PERSONNEL
THANK YOU.
MORNING CARVALLO WITH THEIR
NONDESTRUCTIVE TO GRIP ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO POST.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THEY ARE NONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS FOR MS BERKELEY
AUTHOR.
IF NOT A MISS BURKE YOU CAN
CLOSE THINK YOU AYE IF YOU KNOW
JACK THAT WAS ACTUALLY VERY
TEMPERATE SO I WANT TO THANK
HIM.
FOR HIS. TEMPER HAVE A POSITION.
.
AS FAR AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AYE WE HAVE MET WE MET
EARLIER.
WE MET THE RECENTLY AND IT WAS
ACTUALLY EXTREMELY PRODUCTIVE
AND WE CONTINUE TO WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM.
UP ON THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THE
REASON WE GIVE YOU THE DATE IS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW AS IT STANDS
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ONLY
USES ABOUT TWENTY ONE TO THIRTY
NINE GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS EIGHTY
IS ACTUALLY MORE. SO THE AREAS
WOULD BE SMALLER SO AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON GEOGRAPHICAL
AREAS ALSO I AS FAR AS
NEGOTIATING PRICE THE REASON WE
NEVER DECIDED ON A RANGE WAS
BECAUSE WE PUT IN THE BILL THAT
THERE IS NO MINIMUM AND NO
MAXIMUM. THE IS THE STARTING
POINT AND THEN THEY NEGOTIATION
AND FOR THAT MACHINE IS
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE'VE
ADDRESS OUR ISSUES AND OTHER
ACTUAL ISSUES IN THE BILL
HOWEVER BECAUSE THERE IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL A FORM OF. COMING TO
LIBERATE SURVEY THAT'S OUTSIDE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE%
CURRENTLY BELIEVE THAT'S WHY
THEY CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSE
OUTSIDE OF THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIBEL. GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MS BURKE.
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS LET'S GO
AHEAD AND VOTE.
DALY BY DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES
I'VE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE OF THE ARROW.
CABALLERO AYE CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE CHEN.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER AYE AYE
HARPER AYE.
TENDER THEIR GENDER ZERO WELL
DONE MS BURKE.
IN THE BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS FOR THE MISSING
MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
SO WE HAVE MISTER CALDERON SPILL
IN MISTER HIS ARIENS BILL.
IS SIGN IN ORDER MISTER
CALDERON YOU CONTENT TO MIT LET
MISTER NAZARIAN.
YOU'RE IN THE.
YOU'RE IN THE BATTER'S BOX SIR.
STERN IS ARYAN ON AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN WELCOME TO OUR
HEARING.
THINK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES.
I'M.
IT'S A MATTER OF WHEN AND NOT IF
A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE OCCURS IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE ALL HEARD THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY ONLY ABOUT TEN
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE.
MOST OF IT IS OFFERED THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY THE NOT FOR PROFIT
INSURANCE PROVIDER ESTABLISHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN THE WAKE
OF THE DEVASTATING NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
WHILE C. A. NOW IN SHORTS MORE
THAN ONE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN
THE STATE.
FAR TOO MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
THE LACK FINANCIAL PROTECTION
FOR THE NEXT DAMAGING
EARTHQUAKE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN
CLARIFIES CURRENT STATUTE TO
ALLOW THE C. A.. TO PLACE A
SURCHARGE ON THEIR POLICY
HOLDERS PREMIUMS
BUT ONLY IN THE EVENT OF AN
EXTREMELY LARGE UNPRECEDENTED
EARTHQUAKE.
IT IS UNLIKELY THAT SURCHARGE
WILL EVER BE NEEDED. IT WOULD
TAKE AN EVENT TOUR THREE TIMES
THE SIZE OF WHAT NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE WAS IN ORDER TO GET
TO THAT POINT.
HOWEVER THE VERY EXISTENCE OF
THIS CAPABILITY WILL ALLOW THAT
C. A. TO REDUCED AMOUNT OF
REINSURANCE.
THANK YOU IT MUST THE RELY ON IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BE PREPARED
FOR THE ONE IN THE FOUR HUNDRED
EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE.
.
THERE THIS BILL IS STILL A WORK
IN PROGRESS.
WE'VE GOTTEN IT TO THIS POINT
BUT TARA AYE JOINING ME IS GLENN
POMEROY WHO IS SET WITH A C. A.
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR OR FROM
MISTER POMEROY.
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND LET ME SEE IF ANY PERSONS
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
I SEE A COUPLE MOVE INTO THE
MICROPHONE.
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THE COMMITTEE I'M CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR VICE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD LEGALIZATION
FIONA MA. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
Q..
OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR.
IF NOT THEN WE'LL GO TO PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL.
OR SEMI TWEETERS OR WHATEVER YOU
CALL YOURSELF.
CHAIRMAN RETAIN LEVINE ON BEHALF
THE REINSURANCE ASSOCIATION
AMERICA APPRECIATE DE CURRENT
POSTURE THE BILL WHERE IT IS
CURRENTLY.
AS MISTER NAZARIAN INDICATED
THERE IS A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
IS THIS.
MOVES TO THE PROCESS SO
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS YOUR REAMERS ABOUT
THE AMERICAN INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION SIMILAR POSTURES
MISTER LEVINE A MEADOW WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT CLEAN UP ONCE IN THE
TENT LANGUAGE REFERENCE TO
REINSURANCE UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AFTER
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT WE HAVE.
REMOVED UP THIS FROM THIS BILL.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER.
PERSONS AGAINST THE BILL IF NOT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL AND.
BEFORE US THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND TO MISTER NAZARIAN ANY
OTHER.
COMMENTS IN CLOSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER.
COOL.
ALRIGHT LET'S SIR WILL DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE RIGHT NOW.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAY. MAYES AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE CALDERON. WALDRON
AYE CHEN ON IT CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER I'VE.
COOPER I FRAZIER FONG FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER HIGH. TWELFTH ZERO
ALRIGHT UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL WELL DONE. THANK YOU I
THINK THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME I
GOT A UNANIMOUS VOTE AND THIS
COMMITTEE THREATEN. MILESTONE.
OKAY TREASURE THIS MOMENT.
GILLETTE YEAH.
I'M NOT GONNA SAY ANYTHING ELSE
ON TEN TO TWO.
NOW WE'RE DOWN TO OUR LAST BILL
OF THE. OF THE MORNING MISTER
CALDERON IS BILL.
IT IS SO.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE.
OUR AUGUST COMMITTEE COLLEAGUE.
MISTER CALDERON PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS RESEARCH GOT EASY BILL
TECHNO TIME AT ALL.
.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
TO SUBMIT MORE DETAILED
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AND
REQUIRE CLEAR GET TO ASSESS AND
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON ITS
CAPACITY.
TO HANDLE PROTECTIVE LONG TERM
CARE ENSURE.
INSOLVENCY AS LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FOR
FAMILIES.
IT PROVIDES IMPORTANT FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND HELPS PEOPLE
MAINTAIN DIGNITY AND
INDEPENDENCE IN THEIR LATER
YEARS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE THAT
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES DUE TO CHRONIC
ILLNESS DISABILITY. OR COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT SUCH AS ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE.
THE COST OF LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES
CAN BE SIGNIFICANT AND IT IT IS
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE. IN AN
UPWARD TREND THE MEDIAN COST OF
A ONE YEAR STAY IN A PRIVATE
NURSING HOME IS MORE THAN NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY YEARS
THE SAME STAY WILL COST MORE
THAN A HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WITHOUT LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE MOST PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
TO.
PLEASE THEIR SAVINGS IN ORDER TO
COVERED SUCH COSTS.
ACTUALLY WAS IN THE CASE OF MY
GRANDMOTHER.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN PENN
TREATY A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE PROVIDER WENT
BANKRUPT.
FORTUNATELY CONSUMERS THAT HAD
PURCHASED PANTRY PLANS WERE NOT
LEFT WITHOUT COVERAGE OR A OUT
THE MONEY THEY HAD THOUGHTS FAR
INVESTED THANKS TO THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE GUARANTY ASSOCIATION
ALSO KNOWS CLICK. CLEAR GUY IS
AN ASSOCIATION OF ALL INSURANCE
COMPANIES LICENSE TO SELL LIFE
INSURANCE HEALTH INSURANCE AND
ANNUITIES IN CALIFORNIA IT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY STATUTE IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE JUST WEEKS
BEFORE. EXECUTIVE LIFE INSURANCE
COMPANY WAS DECLARED INSOLVENT
LEGAL WAS CREATED WITH THE
INTENTION OF GIVING POLICY
HOLDERS OF INSOLVENT COMPANIES A
GUARANTEED.
SOURCE OF PAYMENT.
THE GAP BETWEEN PAN TREATIES
ASSESSED ASSETS AND LIABILITIES.
WE'LL HAVE TO BE MADE UP THROUGH
ASSESSMENTS ON DISABILITY
INSURERS WHICH IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ULTIMATELY PASSED ON TO POLICY
HOLDERS TO SURCHARGES. ESTIMATES
SHOW THAT CALIFORNIA POLICY
HOLDERS WHO ULTIMATELY PAY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
SURCHARGES RELATED TO THE PANTRY
INSOLVENCY. THOSE SURCHARGES
WILL ENSURE THAT APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT THOUSAND PENN TREATY
POLICY HOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE ABLE TO GET THEIR CLAIMS
PAID PANTRY DE. PUT THE
CHALLENGES IN THE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE MARKET AND OUR
INSURANCE GUARANTEE SYSTEM INTO
FOCUS. AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
FIVE AS IT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS LIMITED TO PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO HEAD OFF
POTENTIAL INSOLVENCY BY
REQUIRING ROBUST REPORTING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AND
PROVIDES INFORMATION ON KLAY
GETS CAPACITY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS IN THE EVENT THAT
INSOLVENCY TAKES PLACE I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS OUT OF ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS ON THE GUARANTEE
ASSOCIATION UP TO THIS POINT. I
KNOW THERE IS MUCH DEBATE ABOUT
HOW TO ENSURE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED IN THE CASE IN CASE OF
A FUTURE INSOLVENCY. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE WORKED A LOT ON
ENSURE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
EL LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
ISSUES.
AS A MILLENNIAL I FEEL LIKE THIS
IS A MILLENNIAL ISSUE MY PARENTS
ARBED OUR GENERATION OUR PARENTS
WERE PUT IN A POSITION.
TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
RECESSION AND YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED WITH MY FAMILY THEY
LOST THEIR BUSINESS IN THEY LOST
THEIR HOME THEY SPENT ALL OF
THEIR RETIREMENT SAVINGS ALL OF
THE AL EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR THEY
HAD TO TRY TO KEEP THE BUSINESS
ALIVE AND THEY STILL. LOST
EVERYTHING SO THERE IS NO
RETIREMENT FOR THEM AND SO WHO
DOES THAT COSTS FALL ON.
IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY
FOR IT FALLS ON THE KIDS IT
FALLS ON US. AND THIS IS A PLAN
UP THIS THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
OFFER KLAY GOT THIS THIS
ASSOCIATION GUARANTEED
ASSOCIATION EXISTS. IF A COMPANY
DOES NOT.
PROPERLY MANAGE
THERE FUNDS
AND THEY GO INTO AN INSOLVENT
SITUATION THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
JUST LEFT OUT THIS FUND IS A
GUARANTEE FUNDING MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN CONSIST CAN STILL GET
THEIR. THEIR GUARANTEE OF OF
POLICIES AND AGAIN THIS IS PAID
BY ALL THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
PAYING INTO OUR OUR LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE PROVIDERS AND
THEY ONLY PAY IF A COMPANY GOES
INSOLVENT. AND SO THIS BILL JUST
PROVIDES PROTECTION SAYING YOU
KNOW YOU'RE TO REPORT AS AN
INSURANCE COMPANY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
THEN PLEASE GO ALSO HAVE TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR SOLVENT
THAT THEY CAN HANDLE IF THERE
ISN'T INSOLVENCY TAKING ON THESE
NEW CLIENTS. AND ALSO GIVEN THE
ABILITY ARE OF THE ALL THESE NEW
CLIENTS THAT THEY'RE TAKING ON
CLAY GOT TO ASSESS A NEWRATE.
AYE IF THEY NEED TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN COVER ALL OF LONG
TERM CARE COSTS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO INCUR BECAUSE OF THE
INSOLVENCY AND THE BAD ACTIONS
OF A COMPANY.
THAT DO THEIR ACTIONS PUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT SO THAT IS WHAT
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS THAT
IS WHAT THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM DOES TODAY. ARE AND SO WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO.
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
GENTRY AGAIN FROM THE ASSOCIATE
WILL ACT LIKE. AND JOHN MILLION
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA COUNCIL
WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN SHRIEKING AT THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
WE ARE THE SPONSORS THAT THIS
MEASURE.
BEFORE I OFFER SOME REMARKS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK KIRA
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR VERY
DETAILED AND THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS.
I KNOW THIS CAN BE A PRETTY
COMPLEX.
TOPIC AND I THINK THEY DID A
GREAT JOB AND SUMMARIZING THE
ISSUES SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AS SUMMER CALDERON POINTED OUT
THE MOTIVATION FOR THIS BILL WAS
THE INSOLVENCY OF A PENNSYLVANIA
LONG TERM INSURER UNNOTICED
PANTRY.
HE SOLD ROUGHLY EIGHT THOUSAND
POLICIES TO CALIFORNIANS AND
UNFORTUNATE WASN'T ABLE TO KEEP
THOSE PROMISES.
AS MISTER CALDERON REFER TO
THANKFULLY WE HAVE MECHANISM TO
DEAL WITH SITUATIONS LIKE THIS
IN THE FORM OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION OR CLICK HERE.
AFTER PANTRIES INSOLVENCY
QUICKEST THAT DAN AND LOBBIED
ASSESSMENTS ON A GROUP OF HEALTH
AND DISABILITY INSURERS TO RAISE
THE FUNDS NEEDED TO MAKE
POLICIES.
HOLDERS WHOLE.
IN THIS CASE THE SYSTEM WORKED
AND PANTRY HOLDER TAKEN CARE OF
AND NOW THE DUST IS SETTLED
WE'VE HAD SOME TIME TO REFLECT
THE COUPLE ISSUES WERE. BROUGHT
TO OUR ATTENTION.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS THE NEED FOR
MORE FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT OF LONG
TERM CARE INSURERS IN ORDER TO
HELP OUR REGULATORS IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO DETECT AND PREVENT
ANY FUTURE INSOLVENCY.
THOUGHT PROCESSES PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THE BETTER IF WE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB. OF
DETECTING PREVENTING INSOLVENCY
IS THEN ALL TALKS A FUTURE
ASSESSMENTS BECOME PURELY
ACADEMIC.
SO FIRST LINE OF OF OUR OUR
FIRST KIND OF.
DEFENSE IS TO MAKE SURE THESE
GUYS DON'T EVER GO UNDER.
THE SECOND ISSUE WE DISCOVERED
WAS QUICKLY BECAUSE DWINDLING
ASSESSMENT CAPACITY AND THE NEED
TO REVISE THAT METHODOLOGY IN
THE FUTURE.
THIS POINT AGAIN SUMMARIZE ONE
THE COMMITTEE OUT ANALYSIS NOW
WILL GET TOO DEEP INTO DETAILS.
AND FORTUNE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO REACH A CONSENSUS POSITION ON
THAT ISSUE BUT I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE ON IS WHAT'S A PARTY
TODAY AND AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE AND THOSE ARE THE GUARDRAIL
PROVISIONS THAT. A SUMMER
CALDERON JUST FOR REFERENCE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECT WE ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU SIR AND OF THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MANGAN AND I'M REGIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF LIFE INSURERS WERE
THE NATIONAL TRADE GROUP. OF
LIFE LONG TERM CARE IN A NEW TO
COMPANIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THANKS FOR THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. AND
I'M JUST HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
AFTER HEARING FROM THESE MISTER
SHRIEKING AND.
THANK YOU SIR.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PERSONS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL. YET JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS AND.
MARIA GARCIA ON BEHALF OF STATE
FARM INSURANCE IN SUPPORT.
SHERRI MCKEE REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE AND FINANCIAL ADVISORS
AND SUPPORT.
SHE WILL BE TO BE HAPPY UNITED
HEALTHCARE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING JOHN NOR WOULD BEHALF OF
A LIFE INSURANCE COMPANY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JASON SHELTER ABOUT FOR THE
POTENTIAL SUPPORT THAT.
DELYLAH CLAMOR HALF OF NEW YORK
LIFE AND IN SUPPORT.
CRYSTAL JACK ON BEHALF OF CIGNA
IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN PENROD ON BEHALF OF THAT
NOW IN SUPPORT.
THEO PASS A MAP OF HEALTH THAT
IN SUPPORT.
IT MARIN CHAIR MEMBERS MITCHELL
AS ON BEHALF RIGHT HOW FINANCIAL
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IT ANY OTHER PERSONS IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
IF NOT ARE THERE PERSONS
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERESA STARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY.
SHARE THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
POLICY GOALS TO PROTECT THAT
POLICYHOLDERS HERE AND THAT WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE
THE BILL IS HEADED. I ONCE IT
LEAVES THIS HOUSE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD A HE AND
HIS STAFF HAVE BEEN VERY
ACCESSIBLE AND HAVE LISTENED.
I'M A LOT TO US SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT BUT AS OUR LETTER STATES I
THIS BILL AS A VEHICLE FOR A
VERY CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSAL THAT
IS BEING PUSHED BY. THE LARGE
NATIONAL HEALTH INSURERS IN
ORDER TO PULL H. M. O.'S OUR
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS INTO
INSURANCE GUARANTEE ASSOCIATIONS
IN ORDER TO HELP PAY FOR LONG
TERM CARE INSOLVENCY EASE.
THAT'S NOT IN THE BILL BUT IT'S
VERY CLEARLY THE PLAN FOR THE
BILL. AND WE KNOW THIS FOR
SEVERAL REASONS THE MEMBER
COMPANIES OF THE SPONSOR HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN PUSHING THIS I
EXACT LANGUAGE IN SIXTEEN OTHER
STATES. THEY MOVED IT FORWARD AT
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS AND
ACTUALLY THAT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS I AGREE IS A VERY
GOOD ANALYSIS AND IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY TELLING BECAUSE I THINK
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ACTUALLY DISCUSSES.
THIS ACTUAL PROPOSAL THE ENDING
I SEE PROPOSAL I TO PUT H. M.
O.'S IN THE GUARANTEE
ASSOCIATION.
AND AND THE SPONSORS LETTER
ALSO MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THEY ARE INTERESTED IN
SO THERE REALLY IS NO MYSTERY
HERE WE WE KNOW WHAT THEIR GOAL
IS SO. WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT AND BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
I THE FACT THAT THIS BILL MAY
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT OF ONCE IT
LEAVES THIS HOUSE.
WE WANT TO BE CLEAR WE AGREE
THAT THERE IS A POLICY PROBLEM
HERE IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT THE
HEALTH INSURERS ARE HEALTH
INSURER COLLEAGUES HAD TO PAY
THE FULL FREIGHT. OF FOR THE
PENN TREATY ASSESSMENT BUT IF
IT'S A GUARANTEE ASSOCIATION IS
BROKEN IF IT'S NOT WORKING
ANYMORE AND IS NO LONGER
ADEQUATELY PROTECTIVE. OF POLICY
HOLDERS THAT WE NEED TO FIX THAT
IN NOT REARRANGED AT THE DECK
CHAIRS ON THE TITANIC SO. THE
REALITY IS THE ONLY PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE TO REACT TO SO FAR
AND IN OUR TO STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS HAS BEEN. UP THIS
PROPOSAL AND IT ACTUALLY WOULD
BE A TAX
HEARING CALIFORNIA OF THE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THERE IS NO
NEXUS BETWEEN H. M. O.'S AND
GUARANTEE ASSOCIATIONS I WOULD
ACTUALLY TRIGGER ATTACKS. AND BE
A TWO THIRDS VOTE HERE AYE IN
CALIFORNIA AND KAISER PERMANENTE
JUST HAS TO FUNDAMENTALLY OBJECT
TO ANY PROPOSAL THAT WOULD TAX
OUR MEMBERS FOR A BUSINESS THAT
WE'RE NOT IN. A IN FOR MARKET
FAILURES THAT THEY HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH SO AT THE OTHER
HEALTH INSURERS MAY BE
COMFORTABLE DOING THAT.
ON ONTO THEIR MEMBERS BUT BUT
WE'RE NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
SO WE JUST WANTED TO RAISE THAT
ISSUE.
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN THE
HEALTHCARE MARKETPLACE IS
ALREADY VERY SHAKY. AYE COST
CONTAINMENT AND AFFORDABILITY IS
A IS A HOT TOPIC RIGHT NOW IN
HEALTH CARE THIS IS NOT THE TIME
TO BE CONSIDERING A NEW TAX ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS. I'M
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO SKIN
THIS CAT WE CAME UP WITH FOR A
OTHER IDEAS THAT HAD SOME SOME
MERIT IN AND REALLY CONSTRUCTIVE
THOUGHT WERE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO BE.
AT THE TABLE IN AND HELP OUR
HEALTH INSURER COLLEAGUES I
FIGURE OUT THIS PROBLEM.
BUT AGAIN IF THE GUARANTEE
ASSOCIATION ISN'T THE RIGHT
STRUCTURE ANYMORE WE CAN WE CAN
WORK ON THAT SO FOR THESE
REASONS MISTER CHAIRMAN WE FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT. TO BRING THAT
UP.
TO DATE TO BRING UP OUR
CONCERNS AND HOPES OF BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE AUTHORS.
I IN SPONSORS INTENTIONS ARE FOR
WHEN I HAD THE BILL DOES LEAVE
THIS HOUSE AND WE'D LIKE TO SOME
REASSURANCE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
HE IS INTERESTED IN AND
DEVELOPING CONSENSUS BUT WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR THAT THAT IS. HIS
ULTIMATE GOAL I TO GET TO
CONSENSUS AND A AND A GOOD PLACE
I'M ON THE SENATE SIDE AND IF WE
COULD GET THAT COMMITMENT TODAY
THAT WOULD BE A VERY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
MEMBER SCOTT WHICH IN BEHALF OF
MALINA HEALTH CARE. A WE SHARE
THE SAME CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
VOICED BY KAISER RURAL IN A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT POSITION IN
THAT.
AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
MOLINA IT TRADITIONALLY HAS NO
COMMERCIAL LINES. AT ALL.
IT'S BEEN STRICTLY IN THE MEDI
CAL MEDICARE SPACE
RECENTLY WE TOOK ON ABOUT EIGHTY
THOUSAND ENROLLEES IN THE
EXCHANGE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SO UNDER THE.
RUBRIC OF NO GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED BY TAKING ON THOSE
VERY FEW ENROLLEES WE WOULD BE
SUCKED INTO. THE PROPOSED A
HEALTH PLAN TAX.
AND.
AS YOU KNOW IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLANS.
I'D
MILENA DOES NOT PROVIDE NOR CAN
WE PROVIDE.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
US SO BEING THAT WERE STRICTLY
FOR THE FOR ALL INTENSIVE
PURPOSES IN THE GOVERNMENT SPACE
WE DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY.
SPREAD THIS COST LIKE THE OTHER
PLANS DO ACROSS A BROAD BASE OF
OF.
CONSUMERS AND SO ANY HIT THAT
MARINA TAKES A COULD BE
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TO OUR
ABILITY. TO PROVIDE THE CARE
THAT WE DO BECAUSE OUR MARGINS
ARE SO SMALL. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER PERSONS SIR.
WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JOANNE CAMPBELL I'M HERE FOR LA
CARE I JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS THAT ARE
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PERSONS
AGAINST THE BILL QUESTION
SEE MR GRAYSON REACHING FOR HIS
BUTTON THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR
YOUR HARD WORK AND PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND
IF I UNDERSTAND THE TESTIMONY
CORRECTLY IN YOUR PRESENTATION
IN YOUR PRESENTATION YOU'D
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT
THE BILL DOES AS FAR AS
OVERSIGHT. AND PREVENTION.
AND DOUG THEN YOU DIDN'T DRESS
IN MORE OF A CONVERSATION PIECE.
THE NEED TO GIVE ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUE OF ASSESSMENT.
AND THEN IN THE TESTIMONY OF
THE SPONSOR.
YOU MADE IT CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY OVERSIGHT AND
PREVENTION.
AND HAD MENTIONED THAT
ASSESSMENT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE DISCUSSED FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD.
SO IS THE BILL.
IT IS THIS BILL ABOUT OVERSIGHT
AND PREVENTION I SEE IT AS A
THREE LEGGED STOOL ALL THREE OF
THEM NEED ALL THREE OF THEM NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT IF I UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY
THE BILL TODAY IS ONLY
ADDRESSING WITH TO THOSE LEGS AN
THAT'S OVERSIGHT AND PREVENTION
AND NOT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING
ASSESSMENT IS THAT RIGHT YOU'RE
CORRECT.
BUT SO IF IF THAT'S THE CASE
SPEAK.
BUT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE ASSESSMENT
CONVERSATION IS GONNA BE A
SEPARATE CONVERSATION THAT
HAPPENS.
A IF I UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU WERE
MY OFFICE THAT JUST THE OTHER
DAY WE WERE TALKING SOMETIME
DOWN THE ROAD NEXT YEAR OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MIGHT BE. WELL
WE'VE ALREADY HAD A CONVERSATION
WHERE I HAD A LARGE STAKEHOLDER
MEETING AND AND ONE OF THE ROOMS
DOWNSTAIRS BY ALL THE OTHER
COMMITTEE ROOMS. AND SO YOU
KNOW.
THE FIRST TWO LEGS WERE
ADDRESSING IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE A LOT
OF CONSENSUS IS ON WE WOULD
LIKE.
TO FIND THE SOLUTION ON THE
THIRD PIECE ABOUT IT AS I WAS AS
I SAY TO THEM IN THAT MEETING
AYE AND AGAIN HAVE NO PROBLEM
STATING I'M TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
ON BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT THE
GREATER GOOD. I THINK YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY IT'S ON ALL OF US TO
TAKE ON A LITTLE BIT TO TRY TO
TO FIX A LARGER PROBLEM BUT THAT
IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS. IS
DOING TODAY THIS IS ABOUT
PREVENTION IN BEING PREPARED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE PEOPLE THAT
ARE PAYING INTO THESE PLANS THAT
ARE THAT WOULD NEED LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE AT THAT COMPANY
IS IRRESPONSIBLE THEY GO OUT OF
BUSINESS. WHAT HAPPENS ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE CONSTITUENTS
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT AT LEAST
GIVING THAT DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IN THE LEGISLATURE
MORE INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE THESE PROTECTIONS IN THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT JUST LEFT
OUT HIGH AND DRY? YET WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ON EGGS ON
ASSESSMENT BUT LET'S BE CPAS BE
VERY CLEAR THE GOAL IS TO GET A
SIGNATURE ON THIS BILL AS IT
STANDS BECAUSE THIS PROVIDES. A
LOT OF PROTECTIONS TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT'S THE GOAL IF WE
CAN MAKE HEADWAY ON THE OTHER
ISSUE SURE WILL INCLUDED IN BUT
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS IT COMES BACK
TO THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE. IT'S
A MAJOR POLICY CHANGE AND THEN I
GET CALLED IN TO HELP. OUR THAT
INTO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE SO
IT'S NOT LIKE A CUT LEAVE THIS
COMMITTEE AND IT NEVER COMES
BACK IF WE MAKE THAT CHANGE
COMES BACK THIS COMMITTEE AND
GOES AND GOES BACK IN HEALTH. SO
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS SOME EASY
THING THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN ALL IN
BY THE WAY IF THE TAX REQUIRES A
TWO THIRDS VOTE WHICH IS GONNA
BE SO EASY ON THE FLOOR. GRANTED
UPGRADED COUNTY VOTES BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GOING TO BE
EASY SO YOU KNOW THIS IS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH AT HAND IT'S
IT'S ABOUT PREPARE PREVENTION
AND PREPAREDNESS.
AND AND IT'S A GREAT BILL IN ITS
UPON ISSUE. YOU KNOW RETIREMENT
SECURITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
I'M A BIG BELIEVER THAT IF
YOU'RE CONTRIBUTING AND YOU'RE
TRYING TO BE PREPARED AND THAT
THE ACTIONS OF A COMPANY. BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE
DIDN'T TAKE THE PROPER MEASURES
TO PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS.
MAN I JUST DON'T THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE SCREWED BECAUSE OF.
I FEEL YOUR PASSION THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
FOR THE AUTHOR MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND AGAIN.
I CAN APPRECIATE YOUR PERSONAL
INTEREST BECAUSE OF YOUR
GRANDMOTHER.
AND.
AS AN EMPLOYER FOR THE LAST
TWENTY THREE YEARS CRIED BECAME.
A LEGISLATOR.
I PAID EVERY INSURANCE IN THE
BOOK.
A FOR MY EMPLOYEES THROUGH
WORKMEN'S COMP. LIABILITY
INSURANCE.
NO ONE OF THE THINGS IS THAT I
WAS LIKE I NEVER HAD A CLAIM ON
ANY OF THOSE EVEN UNEMPLOYMENT.
BUT FOR ALL THE MONEY THAT I
SPENT I NEVER GOT A REBATE ON
ANY OF IT.
OKAY.
AND SO.
KNOWING THAT SIGNAL WAS A A
SAFETY NET FOR ENSURING. OF
THROUGH A LOT OF THE OTHER
POLICY CENTER ISSUED.
I GAVE ME A LEVEL OF COMFORT AS
AN EMPLOYER.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CONCERNS
ME AND AGAIN I KNOW THAT THERE
HAS TO BE A SAFETY VALVE.
IF IF A.
SAFETY NET IS NOT A ADEQUATE OF
BUT REPORTING TO LEGISLATURE TO
ME.
HE KIND OF A.
.
KIND OF A.
LIKE A LOT PASS OFF.
.
WHERE IS THE INDUSTRY ITSELF
SHOULD BE A SELF GOVERNED AND
MAKE SURE THAT BAY? ARE CAN CAN.
APPROPRIATELY COVER THEIR LOSSES
LIKE WHEN PEOPLE LOST MONEY IN
THE STOCK MARKET IN IT AS YOU
SAID IN A DOWNTURN. NOBODY WAS
FREAKED RECALL BEEN SATED FOR
THAT IT WAS COMPLETE LOSS AND WE
JUST WENT AND WE TOOK OUR LUNCH
SO WE KEPT GOING.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS THE ABILITY TO
TAKE THE RISK
BUT ALSO HAS OF ABILITY TO MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY.
AS YOU SAID THIS IS A VERY VERY
LUCRATIVE. OF AREA WHEN IT'S UP
BECAUSE IT'S SO EXPENSIVE.
SO I'M I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HERE I CAME INTO THIS
JOB AS A LEGISLATOR.
I PAID ONLY INSURANCE PREMIUMS
ARE PAID HEALTH INSURANCE FOR MY
EMPLOYEES.
BUT WE DON'T GET INSURANCE
MEDICAL INSURANCE IN THIS JOB.
I'M CONCERNED IF THERE IS A
SAFETY VALVE THAT PUTS IN OFF ON
THE H. M. O.'S OR OR ANY OF THE
PLANS WHAT'S GONNA COST ME.
THE COVER THAT INDUSTRY.
WHAT'S IT GONNA COST AND I'M
ALSO A UNION MEMBER.
WHAT'S GONNA COSTS MY UNIONS FOR
HIGHER PREMIUMS TO COVER THAT
INDUSTRY
SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW.
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO TRICKLES
DOWN TO THE CONSUMER.
THEY DON'T JUST TO. ABSORB IT
THEY HAVE TO PASS IT ON.
SO CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
TO COST ME MY UNION MEMBERS IF
IT IF THIS GOES FORWARD. OF
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALWAYS IN THIS
BUILDING CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING FOR THEIR MEMBERS
AS FAR AS GOING FOR A MINUTE
TRYING TO PROTECT THAT.
A SORT IF THAT GOES FORWARD I
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE COST WOULD
BE TO THE CONSUMER.
SO IT'S AN INFORMED.
VOTE AS YOU SAY WHEN YOU BRING
IT TO THE FLOOR BACK HERE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW.
.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AS FAR
AS?
PROTECTIONS ON THOSE TO EXISTS
AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY SAID.
ABSOLUTELY AGREE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE AND AND TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE THERE THEIR.
YOU KNOW PROVIDING COVERAGE FOR
AND THE EXPECTATION.
BUT THEY WILL.
.
BUT YOU LOOK AT THE ALSO THE
PEOPLE ARE PAYING FOR THIS
INSURANCE AND IF THEY DIE
SUDDENLY.
CUT BACK ITS ABSORBED BY THE
INSURANCE COMPANY AND I GET THAT
IS OF VALUE.
SO THE WORKS BOTH WAYS AND SOME
LOOKING FOR DEBT. YOU WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY AND AND I
APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR PERSONAL
INTERESTS ARE AS A FORMER
EMPLOYER. YOU KNOW I WANT THOSE
PROTECT.
NOW YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS IT AGAIN YOU AT THAT
ISN'T IN THE BILL AND SO I AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS ONCE
THAT PEACE IS THERE. BUT AGAIN
THAT'S NOT WHY WE PUT WE THAT'S
WHAT WE DID PUT THE PIECE IN
THERE BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
REACH CONSENSUS ON ON THE O.
OVERALL AGREEMENT IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
BUT AGAIN THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
BILL ULTIMATELY DIES AND AGAIN.
IT'S GONNA COME BACK HERE AND
HAVE TO GO TO HEALTH THE HEALTH.
COMMITTEE ULTIMATELY IF THAT
ASSESSMENT IS IS PLACED IN AND
AGAIN IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY.
YOU KNOW FIRST WE GOT EVERY
STATE HAS THEIR OWN GUARANTEED.
ASSOCIATION THAT PLAN THAT THEY
THAT THEY MANAGE
AND SO I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT THEY LEASE REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE AN
ABILITY TO REPAY.
OR TO PAY FOR THE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED TO PAY FOR A ONCE IN
THERE IS AN INSOLVENCY.
THE MEMBER COMPANIES ONLY PAY IF
THERE IS AN INSOLVENCY ARE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT UNDER THE ACA.
WHETHER ALL INSURANCE RETREAT
INSURERS ARE TREATED THE SAME OR
NOT BECAUSE EVEN WHEN YOU GO TO
SIGN UP FOR THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT YOU GO ONLINE. IT DOESN'T
DIFFERENTIATE IT'S EITHER
MANAGED CARE THAT MEANS THERE IS
NO DIFFERENTIATION TO PICK A
PLAN THAT IS YOUR INSURANCE SO
WE CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE ALL DAY
LONG. UP BUT THERE USED TO BE
OVER A HUNDRED PROVIDERS OF LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE NOW WE'RE
DOWN TO TWELVE PROBABLY ELEVEN
ACTUALLY BECAUSE PENN TREATY
WENT OUT OF BUSINESS AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO EXPENSIVE BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE. SO WE REALLY ARE
DEPENDENT UPON THESE FEW
PROVIDERS YOU KNOW SIX OR SEVEN
MAYBE EIGHT LARGE PROVIDERS IN
THE REST PRETTY SMALL. OF OF
MANAGING THEIR MONEY WELL AND
MANAGING THEIR POLICIES WELL SO
THAT THERE IS.
CERTAINTY THERE AND SO TO
REPORT BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IS IMPORTANCE OF A
FROM MANAGERIAL AND PROTECTION
STANDPOINT AND ALSO TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
AGAIN.
GETS ALSO GETS CLICK AT THE
ABILITY FOR THOSE CONSUMERS THAT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE ON DUE TO THE
INSOLVENCY. THEY MEET IT'S THAT
YOU KNOW IF MRS WILSON IS
PROBABLY PAYING TWELVE DOLLARS A
MONTH.
WELL MAYBE THAT'S A REASON WHY
THAT'S THAT THAT BUSINESS WHEN
INSOLVENT BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
CHARGING UP SO KLIEG AS A FIND A
GUARANTEED ASSOCIATION FUND
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF SAYING OKAY. MAYBE
WE NEED TO CHARGE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SO I APOLOGIZE THAT YOUR
RATE IS GOING TO GO UP BUT IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THAT GUARANTEE
WE HAVE TO CHARGE MORE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE CAN
STILL DECLINE THAT RATE INCREASE
BUT THEY STILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ASK IN THIS IS GIVING THEM
THAT THAT ABILITY ASKING IT IS
ON US TO MAKE SURE THAT. THEY
ARE NOT ONLY CHECKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE BUT ALSO
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE INSOLVENCY UP OR
THAT THEY CAN HANDLE ARE. YOU
KNOW THEIR SITUATION AND THE
SITUATION OF EVERYBODY ELSE THAT
THEY'RE TAKING ON IN THE EVENT
THAT THERE IS AN INSOLVENCY DUE
TO BAD ACTORS.
A BUT I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND AGAIN THAT'S RIGHT
JUST NOT IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'M. I ONCE
NEGOTIATED A BILL FOR TWO YEARS
I KNEW I HAD THAT THE VOTES ON
THE FIRST GENERATION BECAUSE I
CARE ABOUT CONSENSUS AND I CARE
ABOUT. REACHING THAT YOU KNOW
COMMONSENSE
SOLUTIONS EH TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITY SO I DON'T THINK ANY OF
YOU NEED TO WORRY ABOUT MY
ABILITY TO BE REASONABLE I TRY
TO BE AS REASONABLE AS I
POSSIBLY CAN. EVERYTIME UP SO
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT I WILL
NEED I WILL I WILL CONTINUE WITH
THESE CONVERSATIONS ON THAT
SIDE.
IT OUT WITH GOOD INTENT AND
ONLY PUT IT IN THE BILL IF I
FEEL LIKE WE'VE WE SOME
CONSENSUS.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND KNOW
ANYTIME AS A CONTRACTOR I TOOK
RISK I HAD TO BOND.
YOU KNOW TO TO ASSURE MY EITHER
MY CLIENT OR OR THE AGENCY THAT
I WAS WORKING FOR. THAT THAT WAS
THAT IF I COULD NOT.
COMPLETE THE PROJECT.
THE BOND WOULD COVER ALL COSTS.
AND MAYBE THE THE AGENCY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SAFETY VALVE
HAS SOME KIND OF ASSURANCE THAT
YOU CAN ALSO DO THAT OTHER THAN
GOING TO THE CONSUMER.
THAT BEING SAID HERE I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT PROP ONE OR
THREE ALSO WHEN INSURERS HAVE TO
GO BACK. SOMETIMES AND I'VE BEEN
TOLD THIS.
THAT NOT ONLY HAVE THEY GONE FOR
AN INCREASE BUT THEY'VE RECEIVED
A DEDUCTION.
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
OF AND SO THEY TAKE A RISK EVERY
TIME THEY GO THROUGH FOR THAT
RATE INCREASE SO I. I I I I I
HAVE I'M HESITANT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT GOING FOR AN INCREASE.
THE FATE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
ALWAYS COME FORWARD AT LIGA.
THAT MEANS THAT SPECIFICALLY THE
GUARANTEED ASSOCIATION FUN NOT
TO THE INSURANCE AT WORK TALK
ABOUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS IS IS.
YOU KNOW HIT HISTORY PREVAILS
ITSELF HILL THROUGH OTHER
THROUGHOUT WE DON'T GIVE THE IF
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THAT ON THE HEALTH UNDERSTOOD
JUST SIMPLY NOT A GUARANTEED
ASSOCIATION ASIDE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT THEY WERE FORCED TO
TAKE ON. ABSOLUTELY AND BASIC I
JUST BETTER ASSURANCES.
MISS KIRBY HERO HAD.
QUESTION OR COMMENT AND THEN
MISTER COOLEY WILL FOLLOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
WELL I JUST AM I WANTED TO THANK
AYES ARE IN MILLION HEALTH CARE
FOR.
UP PRESENTING TODAY.
BEN AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPLANATION FOR HOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON THE BILL. BECAUSE ON
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE THINGS
THAT THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S GOOD TO SEE.
ASSURANCE THAT.
IT WILL BE DONE IN A WAY THAT.
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY EITHER
TO COME BACK OR THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING REALLY FOR A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY IN THAT. IT WILL BE ON
A GOOD PROCESS SO I'M I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL ON
I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL.
I I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
LACK OF OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
TO BUY INTO LONG LONG TERM CARE.
UP MY MOTHER HAS ALZHEIMER'S AND
SHE'S USING LONG TERM CARE AND
QUITE FRANKLY UP WITHOUT IT
SHE'D BE SELLING OFF ALL HER
ASSETS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR HER CARE. AND WE MAY
GET THERE WHEN IT WHEN IT IF AND
WHEN THE LONG TERM CARE ENDS BUT
I. LOOK AT THAT MY FATHER WAS
VERY WISE IN BUYING THE POLICY.
AND MY HUSBAND AND I HAVE BEEN
VERY UNWISE AND NOT. BUYING A
POLICY AND SO ON I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
TSUNAMI OF OF SENIORS GETTING TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY MAY NEED IT
AND.
AND TO HAVE IT AVAILABLE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT IT BE
SOLVENT ISRAELI IMPORTANCE I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL
AND I'M AYE AYE MOVE I MEAN I
MOVE THE BELL BUT I. I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT I'M CONCERNED WITH
THE SECOND PART OF IT AND IF YOU
GET THERE.
AND CAN WORK IT OUT THAT WOULD
BE TERRIFIC TO.
MISTER COOLEY.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
I.
JUST WANT TO SPEAK A LITTLE TO
THE SUBSTANCE OF IT.
AND I SORT OF FEEL LIKE WELCOME
TO LAW MAKING FOR ALL OF US.
THIS BILL INVOLVES THE GUARANTEE
FUND.
THE BASIC
FUNCTION OF OUR INSURANCE SYSTEM
THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH HERE
IS THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE
FOR.
FOR PROMISES BEING PAID IN EVERY
INSTANCE IS THE RATES BEING
PAID.
IT'S NOT THE GUARANTEE FUND IS
ADEQUATE RATES.
THEN AND MAKE IN EVENT THAT FOR
SOME REASON RATES.
PROVIDE REVENUES INSURANCE COVER
NOT ADEQUATE SO THEY END UP
GOING INSOLVENT.
THE SECOND LINE OF DEFENSE IS
ALWAYS THE GUARANTEE FUND.
AND AND THAT'S A BIG POLICY
PUBLIC POLICY CHOICE.
THAT'S TRUE IN THE NDIVIDUAL.
GETTING SCREWED BECAUSE THE
COMPANY WENT BANKRUPT THERE CAME
CAN'T GET PAID.
WE SOCIALIZE AT COST TO
GUARANTEE FUND.
THE COST CONTRIBUTED.
SO WE ARE IN THIS ERA AS THE
ANALYSIS
WALK US THROUGH. THE LEGACY
SYSTEM EARLY RATES FOR LONG TERM
CARE WERE OPTIMISTIC.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM OF IT'S AN
EXPENSIVE TYPE OF COVERAGE.
PEOPLE LIVING LONGER WHICH IS
GREAT FOR THEM.
BUT IT AFFECTS YOUR LIFE
ASSUMPTIONS.
SO WE NOW HAVE AN INSURANCE
SYSTEM WHERE THERE ARE RISKS TO
INSOLVENCY.
SO AGAIN WHAT'S AMERICAN
SOLUTION WE TRY TO CONCEPTUALIZE
A GUARANTEE FUND A WAY TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT.
.
THE STATEOF THE LAW GENERALLY
IN CALIFORNIA'S GOES BACK QUITE
A WAYS IS THAT.
YOU HAVE INSURANCE COMPANIES
WHICH MAY PROVIDE HEALTH
BENEFITS
AND YOU HAVE HEALTH PLANS
THE DRUGS ARE THE PART A MATCH
HEALTH CARE. THAT SHE TWO
DIFFERENT ENTITIES UNDER OUR
LAW.
SO WHILE I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN BEING EXPRESSED BY.
KAISER MOLINA.
LARA AND OTHERS
THEY ARE IN A DIFFERENT BODY OF
LAW.
SO IT ENDS UP FALLING INTO OUR
LACK TO KIND OF GRAPPLE WITH
THIS HOW DO WE PUT.
HOW DO WE? HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORTS.
NOT HAVING THE BURDEN OF
INSOLVENT COMPANY FALL SINGLE IN
AN INDIVIDUAL.
AND.
.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL IT'S OF VERY
APT BILL FOR MAJORITY LEADER TO
BE TRYING TO ADVANCE A
CONVERSATION TO BRING IT
FORWARD.
TO ENGAGE ASSAULT.
ARE.
I'M.
ON THIS SORT OF THING I ALWAYS
THINK OF A SERMON I HEARD WHEN I
WAS EIGHTEEN.
I.
CREATURE CUENTA CHURCH US
ANYMORE AND PRIESTS A SERMON
ABOUT THE SEVEN LAST WORDS IN
THIS CASE OF THE CHURCH.
THE SEVEN LAST WORDS WERE THE
LAST SEVEN THINGS OUR CHURCH
WILL SAY.
BEFORE IT'S GONE FOREVER.
TURNED OUT THE SEVEN LAST WORDS
OF THE CHURCHES WE'VE NEVER DONE
IT THAT WAY BEFORE.
AND SO WE DID IF WE ADOPTED THE
FACE OF CHALLENGING ISSUES THIS
DANCE WITH GOV DOT THAT WAY
BEFORE.
THEN WERE FOR A DEADLOCK.
SO AS I SAY.
A GOOD BILL NOT AN EASY BILL I
SEE THAT THE ARGUMENT WHAT THE
HOME BUT THAT INVOLVES WE
GENERATE OUR LAW.
IN A THOUGHTFUL WAY.
AND.
.
IT'S IT'S NOT SO THAT CAN HAPPEN
IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT
WILL NEED TO BE A LOT OF
SCRUTINY.
I. AND IT DOES FIT WITHIN THAT
GENERAL NATIONAL CONVERSATION
HOW DO WE KEEP THE BURDEN OF A
FAILED COMPANY FALLING ON THE
INDIVIDUAL.
SO I THINK A BRING FORWARD I.
SECOND THE MOTION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
OF.
MISTER CHU. AND THEN MISTER
MAYES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ALSO WANT
TO. THANK A MISTER CALDERON WILL
BRING THIS BILL. OF FOUR AND GO
ALSO SAYING CITY.
KISER AND LENA FOR.
A REACHING OUT TO MY OFFICE.
AND THE DATE YOU DIDN'T REGISTER
AS SU A POSITION BUT YOU'LL
BRING IN SOME CONCERN. OF. BUT I
HEARD YOU KNOW PROMISED HER
CALDERON. DEBT HE'S VERY
COMMITTED TO OF WORKING FOR
SOLUTION. AND JUST LOOKING AT
OTHER LANGUAGE HEALTH THIS BILL
I WILL BE SUPPORTING AGO TO
SPELL.
ALRIGHT AND.
MISTER MAYES.
I JUST OF A QUESTION MAYBE TO IN
AND OUT QUICK COMMENT SO THAT
THIS IS FOR A COURSE FROM
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF THIS A
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
LANGUAGE AS A SPECIMEN IN
REGARDS TO USING THE WORD TAX OF
THAT WE DON'T LIKE SO I JUST
WANT CLARIFICATION. THE
OPPOSITION WHAT WE WOULD BE
VOTING ON TODAY THERE IS NO.
TAX INCREASE THAT IN THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE
SECRETARY ALBRIGHT WITH THAT
WITH THAT THAT'S CORRECT MISTER
MAYES THAT THE QUESTION AND INTO
THE AUTHOR'S POINT ABOUT IF IT'S
PUT IN ON THE SENATE SIDE AND
COMES BACK HERE AS A TAX.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WOULD BE VOTING
ON AT THAT POINT WITH NO
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE IT AS YOU
KNOW IN A BILL COMES BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT'S AN UPPER DOWN
VOTE CAN AMEND ON CONCURRENCE.
SO THEN THIS COMMITTEE AND
POSSIBLY THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WOULD BE IN A POSITION
OF AN UPPER DOWN VOTE ON ATTACKS
AS WELL AS AN UPPER DOWN VOTE ON
THE GOOD LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE
BILL. RIGHT NOW SO I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND YES
IT WOULD COME BACK.
BUT YOU MIGHT BE IN IN A BIT OF
A DIFFICULT SITUATION THAT WE
APPRECIATE HEARING THE AUTHORS
COMMITMENT TODAY THAT. HE WILL
WORK TOWARD CONSENSUS ON THE
SENATE SIDE.
THAT WE HAPPY THAT WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
I I DO WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
AGAIN KAISER PERMANENTE CANNOT
BE OKAY WITH ATTACKS ON HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN ENROLLEES. TO
HELP PAY FOR LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE INSOLVENCY SO I I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT'S CLEAR
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO SKIN
THIS CAT WE ACTUALLY PROVIDED
SEVERAL IDEAS SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
I DON'T WANT THERE TO BE ANY
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT. WHERE WE
CAN WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
YOU AGREE THAT THAT LANGUAGE
DOES NOT DO WHAT WE'RE VOTING
THAT TODAY ACTUALLY SAW?
MISTER CALDERON.
NOT ARE SAYING NO THAT'S NOT
TRUE SOME LITTLE BIT OF IT IN
REGARDS TO PROCESS ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK FOR THIS A
COMMITTEE. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY DISAGREEMENT EFFECT I AGREE
WITH ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ABOUT OF THE NEED A TO
BUILD A MOVE SOME SORT OF POLICY
AFFORD I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. AT THAT WE HAVE A
LONG TERM CARE HEALTHY
MARKETPLACE.
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF. ABOUT
TO TURN FORTY ONE.
AND IS A FORMER FINANCIAL
ADVISER I SHOULD HAVE BOUGHT
THAT THAT TWENTY THREE.
I SHOULD HAVE BOUGHT.
THAT LONG TERM CARE POLICY WHEN
I WAS TWENTY THREE AND I DON'T
HAVE ONE NOW AT FORTY ONE. AND
SO I SHOULD PROBABLY GO OUT GO
TO GO DO THAT BECAUSE.
IT'S IT'S NECESSARY I'M FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD THAT YOU WAITED I
THOUGHT ABOUT IT A BILL COULD
HAVE BEEN YEAH THRUST THE HEIGHT
BICU THAT MIGHT BE.
THERE MIGHT BE BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT A
HEALTHY YOU A HEALTHY
MARKETPLACE.
AND WHAT WE REALIZED IS THAT
SOME OF THOSE GASES.
WAY BACK WHEN AND WHERE WERE
WERE INCORRECT.
AND WE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE GO FORWARD THAT
THERE'S A GUARANTEE THAT IF
YOU'VE BEEN PAYING PREMIUMS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS OF FORTY
YEARS.
THAT THERE'S GOING THERE'S
GOING TO BE A PRODUCT FOR YOU TO
BE ABLE TO DRAW DOWN FROM I'M
WHEN YOU GET TO TO RETIREMENT TO
THE.
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
WE ALSO NEED TO BUILD A RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS AND WHILE THE AUTHOR.
HAS A IT IS WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THE REST OF US THAT
ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BEAT TO BE WORKING
AS WELL. IF IT DOES END UP.
AS A AS AN INCREASE THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A NEXUS AND THEN
IT'S GONNA BE TWO THIRDS WHICH
MEANS THAT BOMB THAT IT'S GONNA
HAVE. TO HAVE TO TAKE BROAD
CONSENSUS THAT TO BE ABLE TO TO
MOVE THAT AND SO EVEN THOUGH
IT'S GOING TO BE ON THE SENATE
SIDE. WE'RE STILL GONNA GET TO
BE ENGAGING IN IN THAT PROCESS
BECAUSE IF NOT IT WORK WHERE NO
ONE IS NOT GONNA MOVE SO.
I'M. WHERE I MET TODAY'S?
I THINK THE POLICIES NECESSARY
I'M GONNA VOTE IN FAVOR OF IT
TENDED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE BUT OF
COURSE RESERVE THE RIGHT. TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THE IN THE
POLICY MAKING PROCESS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
AND IT'S A MAYES JUST TO BE
CLEAR I'M NOT WILLING TO
SACRIFICE WHAT I HAVE IN THIS
BILL. ON SOMETHING THAT IS ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT A LONG SHOT IF
IT DOES COME BACK IN AGAIN.
I HAVE ALL OF YOU ARE VERY
KEENLY AWARE.
MAKE THE MOTIONS ON THE FLOOR TO
SEND BILLS BACKED RULES TO SEND
BILLS BACK TO COMMITTEE. I WOULD
HAVE TO BANK DEAL I WOULD BE THE
ONE MAKING THE MOTION TO SEND MY
BILL NOT JUST BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD CALL BACK
TO RELITIGATE. THE DID THE
CONTENTS BUT ALSO TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE SO IT WOULD GO BACK TO
COMMITTEE. EVEN IF IT WENT OVER
THE SENATE IT HAVE TO COME BACK
AND GO BACK TO COMMITTEE IS LIKE
A BILL. THAT GOT PULLED INTO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES AFTER BEING ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND THEN CAME BACK AND HAD
TO GO BACK TO OURS. ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BUT I STILL
END UP GETTING TO THE FLOOR.
AND IN GETTING IT OUT SO.
IN TERMS OF PROCESS THAT'S
THAT'S THE ANSWER AND AGAIN I'M
NOT WILLING TO SACRIFICE WHAT I
DO HAVE THIS BILL BECAUSE THESE
ARE IMPORTANT. PIECES ARE TO
TAKE ON SOMETHING THAT.
WOULD REQUIRE TAX WOULD REQUIRE
TWO THIRDS VOTE AND WOULD NOT BE
GUARANTEE BECAUSE I'M NOT GONNA
SACRIFICE ALL THING. AND YOU DO
AND WE HEARD THIS BEFORE HIS TO
SAY GET YOUR TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS GET.
GOOD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IF NOT
SIR MEMBERS WE'VE HAD A VERY
THOROUGH DISCUSSION LOT OF GOOD
GIVE AND TAKE ON PROCESS AND ON
ISSUES AND.
WHAT THE FUTURE MAY HOLD SO WERE
MISTER CALDERON IF YOU'D LIKE
TO?
A CLOSER AND THEN WILL VOTE.
I MEMBERS I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
GOOD GOOD ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE
FAILING AYE DALY AYE MAY.
MAYES I BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE.
COMEY ARROW. CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON AYE WALDRON AYE CHEN.
CAN I CHU. CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER I'M COOPER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER AYE HARPER
AYE.
TWELVE TO ZERO THAT WAS TWELVE
ZERO. WE HAVE ONE MISSING MEMBER
I THINK IT'S MISTER COOLEY SO WE
WILL. HOLD THE.
THE ROLE OPEN.
AND NOW.
.
I THINK WE FINISHED WE'VE VOTED
ONCE ON ALL THE BILLS NOW A WILL
STEP THROUGH THE OF BILLS AND DO
ADD ONS.
IF THE NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE COOLEY.
THAT'S.
BONTA
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW.
WE'RE STILL DOING ADD ONS AT
THIS POINT WILL STAY OPEN FOR.
BUT CERTAINLY WAIT FOR MR COOLEY
TO RETURN SO WILL BE.
.
HEARING A BE OPEN FOR AWHILE.
GO AHEAD JC TWENTY TO SEVENTY
SIX.
COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE TWELFTH ZERO.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE.
COOLEY.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN
GIPSON.
ABSENT AYE THAT'S THIRTEEN TO
ZERO.
AB THIRTY ONE HUNDRED.
BIGELOW. I KNOW BIGELOW AYE.
CALDERON AYE AYE CALDERON AYE
COOLEY AYE AYE COOLEY AYE.
GIPSON.
ABSENT AYE THE THIRTEENTH ZERO.
AND THEN THE CONSENT.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE GOT THE ARROW.
CABALLERO AYE CHU. CHU AYE.
I'VE COOPE AYE GREAT.
GRAYSON AYE THIRTEEN ZERO.
BUT WAS YEAH.
COULD NOT.
COOLEY.
WE GOD AB NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE THIRTEEN
THIS THERE ARE. AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY SIX.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE THAT'S
THIRTEEN DESERVE.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE
COOLEY AYE AYE COOLEY PRIVATE
THIRTEEN DESERVE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN THAT
ONE'S THIRTEEN TO ZERO THIRTY
ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN THIS ARROW.
AND THE CONTENT THIRTEEN ZERO.
I THINK GO ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF VOTED ON EVERY BILL THANK YOU
TRACY THANK YOU MARK.
THE HEARING IS ADJOURNED